hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that just finished uh in round
seven uh in a game between fabiano
caruana and maxine vashel agrav from the
tata steel 2021
uh it's a really crazy game we're not
gonna have any sort of an intro we
better dive straight into it because i
have no idea how long this video will
take
it's uh it's quite to the game and as
you can imagine
uh with fabi playing it's going to be a
super complicated game
so let's see what happened here fabi
with the white pieces
opens with e4 and of course you all know
what maxime
replies when he sees an e4 on the board
he goes for c5
uh the sicilian defense knight to f3 d6
and the d4
we have captures captures knight to f6
and now
knight to c3 and of course a6 we have
the knight of variation of the sicilian
on the board
and fabi goes for bishop to g5 so you
we've already seen uh two rounds ago uh
niels glendale just played this against
maxima sherlock
and neil's got a beautiful victory
against maksim so let's see
uh if uh if maxine prepared something uh
different for fabi
with e6 f4 and now queen to b6 again
going for the poison pawn variation like
in
a maxim's game against nils uh and the
fabio of course uh
gives up the pawn queen d2 we have queen
captures and now
rook to b1 we mentioned that the fischer
spacek game where knight the b3 was
played
uh but nowadays that that is easily
defended against so rugby one
queen to a3 and now uh in the games uh
in the game niels granddale's versus
maximum varsity legra we had this
f5 move by niels uh but here bishop to
e2 by fabi
so uh going uh in a different direction
maxine continues development knight to
c6 and here
fabi captures we have captures captures
and now the immediate e5 and here
uh maxim needs to decide what to do here
capturing on e5 is very dangerous
because after captures and captures your
only move is knight
to d5 or d7 otherwise you might get
checkmated if if the knight moves to a
weird square so for example knight to d5
you throw in this
rook to b3 move to kick away the black
queen queen to a5 and now you castle and
already
it's a very dangerous position the black
king is still in the center of the board
and even if bishop to c5 check king h1
and castles now
white has this knight captures on d5
with a discovery on the black queen so
here you have to trade
captures and now you deliver this
beautiful knight to f6
check g captures to mess up a black
spawn structure and only now bishop
captures back the queen
we will get this position where the
material is uh equal equalish
uh both players two bishops two rooks uh
but white has
excellent attacking chances and black
would not have a very good time here
so instead after this e5 move we don't
capture uh sorry about that we go
knight to d5 instead and it is only now
as of move 12 we have a completely new
uh
uh position in the game so let's see
what happens here
uh we have knight captures by fabi and
interestingly
uh and i cannot stress uh how how
interesting this is
uh so we reach a a in a completely new
game uh as of move 12. uh
fabi plays knight captures on d5 and
maxine goes
e captures on d5 and unbelievable as it
is
this move loses the game so black has to
capture with the c
pawn here but it's not it's not easy to
spot why uh e catrice and d5 loses the
game so
even even pause the video and try to
find this idea
why it has in this position while i give
you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations i'm always looking
for that pawn push and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
it's e6 and e6 is such a
beautiful move it took fabi a long time
it took him forever to play this movie i
think some 35 minutes
and then it took maxime or even more
than that to reply to this move so for
this one particular move move 14 the
player spent
over an hour thinking about the position
so fabi uh
thought about the the position for some
three 35 minutes and maxine for some
40 maybe 41 minutes and in the end the
maxim decided to keep the position
closed with f6 and this also comes with
an attack on
uh fabi's bishop but let's see what
happens if the e6 pawn is captured as
this is
what interests us so bishop captures an
e6 makes sense it doesn't
mess up your pawn structure uh you pick
up the pawn but then
f5 comes and what do you play now uh
well whatever you play uh white's next
move is castles and
he brings the rook into the game your
king is still here and even if you
capture the pawn
this comes with tempo so the bishop is
under attack
and even if let's say queen c5 check
king h1 and g6 now defending the bishop
bishop to f6 now comes and the dead king
is staying
in the center of the board you are not
castling here you have to play rook to
g8 now you're not castling king side
you're not castling queen side rook the
e1 is coming rook to b7 is coming
everything is coming there's just no no
playing this
so that's what happens if bishop
captures on f6 is played after five is
e6 so definitely a lot to consider here
so what happens if f captures an e6 then
again
f5 you won't open up the position e5 by
black
and now again castles and it seems like
seems like black is doing okay but not
really for example if h6 you just play
f6 and what can what can you do here
accepting accepting the bishop is very
dangerous if h captures here
then f captures on g7 attacking both the
bishop and the rook
and after bishop captures queen captures
on g5 and black's entire position
falls apart so what you would have to do
after f6
uh is probably g6 but then just f7 with
check and this is just unplayable for
black black will
black will suffer immensely to just uh
you know stay in the game
so uh what happens after e6 is that uh
this doesn't work this doesn't work uh
we already uh showed what maxine played
but the engine's favorite is h6 but it
also doesn't work so h6
results in a queen rook to b3 attacking
the queen queen a4
now bishop back to h4 and now only after
uh or
black offers a trade of bishops now you
capture here captures with
check captures captures captures uh
sorry
captures captures and now castles and
now you have a king on e7
can you survive this very very unlikely
so here after this uh e6 move with f6 by
black
not allowing any opening of the position
and now
uh now bishop the h5 with check here
an incredibly difficult position uh fabi
obviously did not have this
everything analyzed as rook to b3 is a
crucial move in all of these lines
because now
uh it's very very hard for for black to
play a move probably queen c5 not
allowing white to castle
but in first interesting stuff happens
if for example queen captures on a2 then
you get queen c3
goes after the pawn also guards against
queen to a1 check
c5 defending against this and now bishop
captures an f6 just uh disgusting
uh if you capture then the queen comes
into the attack and of course if bishop
captures an e6 which is your other
option
then rook to b7 and it's a complete mess
of a position
if d4 challenging the queen you have
bishop to h5
check g6 and now even queen to f3
trying to connect some very uh very uh
you know
distant dots here and let's say queen d5
offering a queen trade
now you can just castle but even if
black is successful in trading queens
captures captures
uh your position will be just just a
dead lost here there's not gonna be a
lot for you to do here
uh especially if rook to e1 comes then
then black is just without a move
so uh the maxim is working on some very
thin ice here but okay
after f6 fabie doesn't go for rook to b3
he goes bishop to h5 with check
and now uh comes a move that's very very
interesting
king to d8 and now as the bishop is
under attack bishop to h4 in here
uh okay fabi has maksim's king on the
run but maxine plays a
such a spectacular move that i when i
saw it i was like
wow uh it's such a such a brilliant move
that
uh it's hard to imagine that such a move
even exists in this position so he
plays d4 here and once you see it then
it starts making sense because now
you're threatening to trade queens even
if castles then just queen to e3 again
trades queens by force
if you don't do anything if you capture
the pawn for example queen captures on
d4 then queen to a5
check and then you have to realize your
bishop also hangs here
but it's uh it's too early to capture
the bishop for example if c3 bishop
queen captures an h5 then queen to b6
check is just deadly king to e7 you're
going to get
queen to c7 with check king captures on
e6
and now after castles it's just uh uh
it's just a one-man game that king is
just stuck in the center here
especially if you capture the bishop
just f5 check king goes here
queen captures there's nothing for you
to do here it's just going to be game
over
so what you would have to do after c3 is
not go after the bishop you have to uh
eliminate the e6 pawn
and now after only now after castles
queen to c5 and the game
game goes on so this is uh what uh what
was in the position after this d4 move
so maximum is definitely on to something
so fabi ignores him and goes uh uh queen
sorry uh fabi ignores him he plays
bishop to f2 now just
attacking that uh pawn uh on d4 with the
bishop
and here maxim immediately goes queen to
c3 and offers a queen trade and the
situation on the clock is
40 minutes each so uh you know after all
that craziness
they still have plenty of time but it's
only move 17 they have to reach move 40
to gain time control so here f5
fabi says i don't mind trading queens uh
good luck surviving this uh
pawn chain here uh maxine trades as
there's
really not not a better move here
captures captures and
now c5 strengthens his pawn in the
center
and fabi now needs to find how to
continue this game uh it's not easy for
maxine to develop his pieces so fabi
needs to take advantage of that he goes
uh
bishop to f3 attacking the rook
rook to a7 and now a g4 just
strengthening the pawn chain here you
could also consider just marching your
king of the board
and here we have g6 challenging the
spawn chain
and now again bishop to h for
threatening check to win material here
so bishop to e7 uh g5
is what fabio was going for if maxine
closes the position with the g5 after
bishop to g3
black will not have a single move to
play uh for for the
rest of the game if you try opening up
the position here
it doesn't really work here for black
because after h4
uh h captures and g for h captures and
g5 now
attacking black's rook captures captures
black's position is hopeless here even
if you grab the piece here
just rook the h8 and there's not much
for you to do rook
akin to e8 just bishop captures on d6
and again
everything just falls apart here bishop
captures an e6 you have to play
something
and there is no defense against this if
rookie seven you're just going to ignore
him play
g6 and now again not much for you to do
there
uh if f2 just g7 and that's just it
f1 queen you're gonna get uh any move
delivers checkmate here basically
so this is what is in the position if
black goes for g5 so
that's just showing that black cannot
get any counter play by by opening up
the h file
but without opening up the h5 black has
no no moves
so bishop to e7 instead by maxime and
now rook to b6
uh we're gaining a lot of activity with
this rook uh
plan is to put pressure on the d6 spawn
here if possible then you can
even double up rooks here if needed so
here we have
h5 by maxine and now just h3 uh so
again not not much can be done if this
is uh captured for example captures
captures
and now again there's no way to take
advantage of this if you play a move
then bishop
g3 again goes after this pawn and
once you once this is played black will
not be able to to defend this
so it's similar to what happened in the
game after this h3 move will queen the
king the e8 by maxine and now bishop to
g3
just going after that pawn we have
rooked the c7
trying to i guess push some pawns here
and now king to d3 fobby no rush to
capture anything you can capture this
you can capture whatever but
fabi just starts improving the position
of the king as there is nothing for
black to do to improve his position so h
captures on g for h captures rook
captures bishop captures and now even g
captures on f5 we have g captures on f5
and now bishop to f8
for the lack of a better move came to c4
fabi just starts bringing his king into
the game
rook to h7 a nice active move with the
rook but just bishop to e4
uh we have bishop to e7 and now finally
fabi grabs the d6 pawn bishop captures
on d6
bishop captures rook captures and here
bishop to b7
offering a trade of bishops and here the
situation on the clock is
some seven minutes for fobby 15 minutes
for maxine
and fabi needs to decide what to do here
does he trade bishops uh or does he need
to look for a better move
so he doesn't have all the time in the
world but he spent a few minutes
deciding on what to play here and he
decided to capture the bishop
but i am going to show what happens
after bishop the c6 check because it's
just awesome
uh you have to capture the bishop
otherwise if you move the king consider
check and you lose the rook or check
check and then you lose the rook
so the bishop must be captured and after
rook captures on c6 it's just uh
it's just game over for black the king
is coming here and you're either
checkmating the
the king or you can just start picking
up all of these spawns uh
either either of the two works so
instead of that fabi i guess decided not
to calculate he figured bishop captures
on b7 was sufficient for a win so this
is what he played
rook captures and now he just grabbed
all the material rook captures on a6
rook to b2 by maxime captures on c5
capture sun
uh c2 with check we have captures on d4
and it was in this position almost 37
that maxine vasher legrov resigned the
game
as there is nothing more to be done you
are uh down two pawns and of course
with without uh without an active move
so of course maxim
does not uh want to continue playing
this
so a spectacular game by fabi
spectacular
moved that e6 idea after this e captures
on d5
which uh maxime so so quickly captured
uh but this is this is what i mean so
second game
uh in the poison pawn variation that
maksim loses in a row
uh so what's happening here we always
say that maxim is the absolute top
authority on the sicilian on all these
crazy lines of the sicilian
but he like if you just uh you know
compared
someone else's knowledge to maxima of
course maximus knowledge is you know
far far greater but here uh like like
niels grandillo's two runs before
uh prepared this specific line and of
course maxine cannot know
everything about every move in every
line so he took him
caught him by surprise here maxim made
the the mistake of capturing with the e
pawn instead of with the c
pawn and you know what do you what are
you going to do uh but
but it's such a funny mistake because
even even if you just consider chess
principle
chess principles if it doesn't to ruin
your position you should always capture
towards the center not away from the
center
uh but here i guess maxim was just uh he
was
maybe sure of himself that he was you
know within the safety of his own
uh home analysis when in fact he wasn't
and fabi he immediately took advantage
of this with e6
so really crazy game uh this video took
some time you know
we could have made it twice as long
three times as long because there are
too many lines here to explore but like
i said
it's what happens when uh players play
these crazy engine lines and you know
fabi just loves loves to complicate
things and here uh he
he he he he came on top uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
i think there were some plenty of other
uh decisive games in this round so we're
going to cover some others
before we check out the standings i
would like to thank gary kieron
allen ferns bupandra sujitra johan
bridger and brian kaplan for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the tata
steel checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your weekend